hey everyone it's Warren and like I said
yesterday the closer we get to Avengers
in game coming out the more leaks were
going to get and yesterday we got a
pretty big leak that confirms two
different things
so I'll be talking about it and breaking
it down in this video also sorry my
voice sounds kind of weird I'm really
sick right now but I wanted to get this
video out so a few months ago we got
some leaked descriptions for some Lego
sets and one of them was a set called
the war machine crusher
well that set has actually finally
leaked and it's not called the war
machine crusher it's called the war
machine Buster just like the Hulkbuster
as you can see it's pretty much just
like the Hulk Buster with the exception
of a few different weapons but it's huge
it's a massive armor for war machine we
know from other leaks that Rody's armor
is getting an upgrade so it would make
sense that he would also get a war
machine Buster when the leaked
description for this came out we weren't
really sure what exactly a war machine
crusher was some people thought it could
have been some sort of a vehicle like a
tank but now it's confirmed that it's
actually a war machine buster but an
even bigger confirmation is in the
bottom right hand corner of this piece
we can see pieces of Ant Man and war
machine wearing their white suits many
people still think that these white
suits are fake and they're not real
mostly due to the fact that they've only
seen them in concept art design photos
or toy leaks that they think are fake
but here we have an actual box for a
Lego set for Avengers in game that has
Rhodey and ant-man wearing these white
suits and that is something really
interesting about this Lego set is that
it has ant-man included
why is ant-man included in this war
machine Buster Lego set well perhaps
it's because war machine and ant-man are
going to go on a mission of their own
and this could actually reveal something
pretty big about the Avengers in-game
Super Bowl TV spot that we saw in the TV
spot we saw one scene with war machine
and ant-man
war machine puts on his helmet as
ant-man prepares to shrink it clearly
seems like they're both about to go do
something together maybe they're about
to go inside of the quantum realm
together we know that the Russo brothers
and Marvel have a lot of misdirection in
their trailers for the Avengers movies
and the wrister brothers themselves have
said that they even use CG
to mess with certain scenes to not give
everything away so maybe in the TV spot
where we see war machine and ant-man
together they're actually wearing these
white suits and are about to go inside
of the quantum realm together they
definitely would not want us seeing
these white suits in the trailer it
would give too much away but now we have
a leak with ant-man and war machine both
wearing these white suits and they're in
the same Lego set together so this
confirms that they'll be wearing these
suits at some point in time but I
actually think they're wearing these
suits in the TV spot for the Super Bowl
that we got and Marvel just edited this
scene to not give it away they did this
for infinity war so you can bet that
they're going to do it for Avengers in
game as well another thing to note is
that in the bottom left of this box you
can see Chitauri and outriders so it
looks like they'll be making their way
back for the next movie so let me know
what you think about this new league
what do you think about the new war
machine Buster and what do you think
about these new white suits and let me
know if you think that war machine and
ant-man are actually wearing these white
suits in the big game TV spot let me
know in the comments down below and
reminder I started a new giveaway giving
away five imax tickets so you and some
friends can go see Captain Marvel or
Avengers in-game in IMAX if you'd like
to enter for your chance to win all you
have to do is subscribe to my channel
like this video and comment down below
with your thoughts in your favorite
superhero or villain as always thank you
all so much for watching woof woof
[Music]
you